kourtney kardashian shuts down theories
that she hates filming her family's
reality series i'm just like living life
and
whatever happens happens
fans of keeping up with the kardashians
know that during its 20-season run
court didn't always come off like she
loved the gig in fact court wanting to
quit the show was an actual storyline on
the series i've decided to take a big
step back from filming and really
just pick and choose what i
will allow cameras to follow
court eventually decided to stay on the
show but established some boundaries i'm
just
decided to
spend more time as a mom and you know
put more of my energy there but i'm not
saying goodbye
of course now court and her famous fam
are set to return to reality tv with a
new series on hulu and kourt is
reflecting on how things have changed in
a new interview with bustle
explaining that shooting the show in the
past was really toxic adding that there
was a lot going on and personally she
wasn't in the happiest place quote i
felt like i was being almost a character
this is courtney and she's in a bad mood
i just i'm like
i don't like
being a celebrity
court says that it got so bad she had to
give herself pep talks before cameras
started rolling quote i'd be like it's
going to be a good day let's have a good
mood let's put a smile on our face yeah
if you're familiar with the
many gifts of courtney on the internet
you can probably guess that didn't
always work if i didn't want to work my
ass off and i wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom that's [ __ ] fine
but now court says a lot of growth came
from those unhappy places which made it
all worth it quote if we didn't go
through these roller coasters you
wouldn't get to the good part
and leading up to the april 14th
premiere of the kardashians on hulu she
insists
there's no one i'd rather spend time
with than my sisters do you think the
show can continue going if you lose a
sister yeah i mean we definitely love
courtney and we will miss courtney but
people come people go all the time this
family we feel like it's a revolving
door so courtney might leave this week
she'll be back they all come back fans
got their first look at the new series
last month
and court says fans were quick to point
out that she already looks over it and
miserable in the promo i'm not putting
my energy there but the reality star
insists she was super sick the two days
they filmed it and her attitude toward
the reboot is a restart quote work-wise
i'm happier than i've ever been i love
it of course personally she's pretty
happy too thanks in part to her
relationship with blink 182 drummer
travis barker
i love you
[Music]
and in a new trailer it looks like their
romance will be heavily featured fans
will just have to wait to see how much
court is willing to show this time
around but we do know this travis's ex
and the mom of his two kiddos landon in
alabama told et she's totally cool with
them making an appearance on the
kardashians new show
i won't be tuning in
however
you know i think it's fine if you know
this is an opportunity that they want to
be a part of and you know my main
concern is always you know my children
are my first priority and you know
that's one thing that you know travis
and i you know do agree on it's probably
the only thing we agree on but you know
our children come first and their
happiness and as long as you know the
kardashians are good to my kids you know
that's all that matters to me as a mom
you know as long as they're happy and
then you know that's that's the key
[Music]
you